a Fox News Alert a remarkable scene in
Asia today firstly you're looking at
live pictures of Anchorage Alaska where
the three US citizens detained by the
North Korean government are flying out
there on the way back from North Korea
they were released by the regime there
ahead of a summit meeting with President
Trump the prisoners were accompanied by
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo to be
landing at Joint Base Andrews right
outside Washington DC overnight the
president said he will meet them there
just a few minutes ago they made it back
as you're seeing now to American soil
that's the second plane taking off Fox
chief national correspondent Henry has
details and what we're watching Tucker
you good to see a major coup from
President Trump is his new Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo is coming home from
his second secret trip to North Korea in
recent weeks with a major foreign policy
victory until it caps a dramatic day of
diplomacy these images that you
mentioned the last few moments the three
previously imprisoned Americans landing
with Pompeo in Anchorage for that
refueling stop they're on separate
planes because the larger plane has
medical facilities for these three
Americans to make sure they're okay
there will be at Joint Base Andrews as
you mentioned just a few hours from now
landing in the middle of the night after
a days of ups and downs some uncertainty
about whether this was really happening
after Secretary of State spent 90
minutes meeting with King jong-un and
then returned to his hotel reporters at
the hotel asked palm bail if the
Americans were coming home he crossed
his fingers because it was still not a
done deal until a North Korean official
soon arrived to say these Americans were
indeed free the three of them you can
see him there Tony Kim Kim hak Song and
kim gyeong-cheol appeared to be in good
health which is a big deal because of
the heartbreak we all felt after otto
warmbier was released from north korea
only to die shortly thereafter because
of the horrific way he was treated by
the communist nation so the focus
tonight is on these three free Americans
so the president is already looking
ahead at how this sets the table for his
summit with Kim that is likely coming in
early June president's saying today this
will be a great moment for the entire
world a short time ago the president
tweeted quote looking forward to
greeting the hostages no longer hostages
at 2:00 a.m.
Fox News will be there I'm gonna be
hosting live coverage in the middle of
night the president we expect with Vice
President Mike Pence as well greeting
them on American soil one
the president's critics were charging
his hot rhetoric was gonna start a
nuclear war instead that tough talk is
bringing home three Americans and teeing
up a possible peace of peace summit
Tucker ed Henry a remarkable story
unexpected story yep thanks for that
release obviously a good sign how
optimistic should the rest of us be
though for long term peace in the Korean
Peninsula where is this headed Erik kasi
honest is director of Defense studies at
the Center for the national interest and
a specialist in North Korea he joins us
tonight
Shari where is this going you know the
pictures are mind-blowing that the photo
ops are amazing but I'm still a little
skeptical and I think we have a lot of
reason here to still week skeptical
talker think about it this way Kim
jong-un is the equivalent of Michael
Corleone literally being dropped into a
country and running his own private
fiefdom they sell drugs around the world
they counterfeit US dollars the Kim
family is literally responsible for the
death of millions of North Koreans and
South Koreans if you lump in the Korean
War so we have reason to be skeptical
however I am a little bit optimistic
this situation might be a little bit
different we have to remember that the
North Koreans are under tremendous
pressure this maximum pressure campaign
is completely different than what we've
seen before because we actually have
buy-in from the Chinese this time now in
previous two attempts when we've tried
to put a lot of pressure on the North
Koreans the Chinese would enforce the
sanctions for a couple weeks a few
months then they would drop off this
time they've actually been a lot more
consistent and applying the pressure
that we need to box the North Koreans in
so now I think the time to strike I'm
very skeptical
history screams out to us to be
skeptical but I'm a little bit more
optimistic and yet they are releasing
these three American citizens who are
they and under what pretext were they
held well I think a lot of it is
basically one of the German I believe
was a farmer now there was a professor
know there was an entrepreneur and a lot
of these people are going to North Korea
because they want to try and do good
they're working in universities they're
trying to build people-to-people collect
connections that's a smart idea I think
it's good that they've been released but
there's a question I just can't get out
of my mind Tucker
what does kim jeong-hoon want for his
nuclear weapons that's the cloud that's
hanging over this whole summit does he
want a hundred billion dollars I mean
it's obvious he wants security
guarantees he wants his regime to be
secure that's the question we need to
ask and I hope that President Trump is
asking them is it fair to assume that
that
rhetoric that it had was referring to
earlier from last year that was so
widely criticized President Trump just
took it right verbally to the North
Korean regime and was denounced as kind
of a lunatic by Americans here that
seems to have borne fruit in a way that
preview previous efforts haven't is that
fair I think that's fair I think the
rhetoric is important but I think the
policies have made a difference here
because at the end of the day Tucker
even if we can't get kim jungeun to give
up his nuclear weapons we have a policy
that would work and we've talked about
this before
it's called containment that's really
all what maximum pressure is it's
containment on steroids we boxed the
North Koreans in if they don't want to
give up their nuclear weapons fine we've
dealt with other countries that have had
nuclear weapons in the past that are
threat to us Soviet Union have thousands
of nuclear weapons we handle that
effectively we can do this so we have
the right policies we're not yet on the
brink of nuclear war like we talked
about last year we're safe we're okay
it's a bad threat it's an existential
threat but we know how to handle these
threats impressive really I don't think
anyone would have predicted this at all
Harry thank you very much thank you